je
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos enregistrés
depuis le technocentre renault de
guyancourt premier centre de recherche
et développement de l'automobile en
europe
et justement ce mois ci nous nous
intéressons à l'économie locale à
travers cette question et si la solution
c'est l innovation pour la reprise
économique c'est parti pour le sommaire
la reprise économique par le
développement du véhicule vert c'est la
stratégie de l'entreprise emitech
spécialisée dans les tests industriels
est implantée à montigny le bretonneux
notamment avec de l'activité sur des
batteries de voitures électriques pour
les pme tpe et micro entrepreneurs
l'innovation peut-elle permettre un
redémarrage de leur activité la réponse
avec deux consultants en transformation
numérique et transition environnementale
la reprise peut passer aussi par la
collaboration entre des sociétés
c'est l'option choisie par segula
technologies groupe d'ingénierie situées
à trappes avec movéo il lance la sécu la
cleantech challenge pour les pme et les
start up
[Musique]
l'innovation c'est le coeur de
l'activité du technocentre du groupe
renault à guyancourt les défis de demain
autour du véhicule autonome et autour du
véhicule électrique sont la
préoccupation des ingénieurs de ce site
écoutez à ce propos est lente à vielle
et la directrice du technocentre renault
de guyancourt
on est dans l'industrie automobile
confronté à une vraie rupture à une
transition écologique également et donc
on a besoin de nous adapter et c'est ici
finalement qu'on va concevoir des
véhicules qui vont nous permettre de
respecter ces défis de man renault a été
précurseur sur véhicule électrique donc
effectivement vous par kenzo et qui fait
beaucoup de ventes en france et en
europe et donc pour nous c'est vraiment
clé de continuer sur cette lancée
après mon rôle moi je suis pas ingénieur
mon rôle c'est le rôle de patron
d'établissement aisément de permettre
que nos ingénieurs développent ici au
technocentre
ce qui nous permettra de faire face aux
défis de demain la majorité de son
activité réalisée dans le secteur de
l'automobile et de l'aéronautique
le groupe et mitec a été frappée par la
crise comme de nombreuses entreprises
cette société implantée à montigny le
bretonneux et spécialisée dans les
essais dans le cadre de qualifications
ou d'homologation avant
commercialisation actuellement et
relance son activité à travers des tests
autour du véhicule vert à regarder et si
la relance de l'activité économique
passée par l'innovation technologique
dans l'économie verte
c'est une part de la stratégie choisie
par le groupe emi tech spécialisée dans
les tests de qualification et
d'homologation
elle a relancé son activité notamment
sur des batteries destinées à des
véhicules électriques
là dessus sur tout ce qui est véhiculé
hybrides ou tout électriques bon on a un
très très bon
marcher très fort et on développe
actuellement je pense des nouvelles
méthodes d'essai pour que demain on
puisse mieux tester tous les véhicules
journal décidé de lancer des bandes test
de moteurs électriques et cela testé et
dans des cages de faraday pour mesurer
les perturbations éventuellement émises
par ces moteurs et aussi d'un dé chambre
anéchoïque acoustique voir ou écouter
plutôt si les moteurs de pompe la peau
bruit avec ces méthodes de tests
innovantes emitech devrait recevoir une
troisième batterie en septembre à partir
du mois d'octobre des tests seront
lancés sur des piles à combustible à
hydrogène
le véhicule vers un moyen pour ce groupe
de 500 salariés de relancer son activité
sous traitant de grands groupes la crise
sanitaire a eu des conséquences
importantes sur cette société
pas de donneur d'ordre donc pas de
chiffre d'affaires ou très très peu sur
des affaires qu'on avait commencé donc
en avril mais on tournait 40% du chiffre
d'affaires tant dans l'automobile que
dans l'aéronautique a rien eu du tout -
soyons clairs donc pendant quatre
pendant dix semaines et aujourd'hui leur
nautique c'est le calme plat mais
l'automobile commence à frémir grâce au
cir est aux véhicules verts pour cette
entreprise implantée à montigny le
bretonneux les deux tiers de l'activité
sont réalisés dans l'aéronautique et
l'automobile
ils représentent plus de 60% des
missions de l'entreprise en 2019
[Musique]
comme l'ensemble des entreprises les
petites sociétés les micro entrepreneurs
ou encore les indépendants qui ont été
frappés par la crise économique
l'innovation peut-elle le booster leurs
activités c'est la question à laquelle
on découvre nos deux consultants bonjour
karim donne l experte en réduction et
gestion des déchets bonjour et j'envie
desranleau bonjour vous êtes consultant
en transformation numérique
pourquoi selon vous de l'innovation
peut-elle être la solution pour la
reprise économique notamment pour les
tpe pme ou encore les indépendants
l'innovation bah elle va être nécessaire
pour retrouver un petit peu de
ressources et elle va et c'est aussi
sûrement être un petit peu nécessaire
parce qu'il ya des nouvelles contraintes
légales qui vont imposer de changer de
manière de faire donc d'innover surtout
dans le domaine de la transition
écologique ou des lois sont sont sortis
en début d'année pour que l'on change
nos pratiques et donc va falloir
sûrement créer de nouvelles manières de
faire plus plus proche et plus
respectueuse de l'environnement
votre gare jean philippe béran loupe sur
le lien entre innovation et reprise
économique pour les tpe pme et les
entrepreneurs alors les tpe ou pme une
écran entrepreneurs ont une capacité et
une qualité énorme qui est leur agilité
alors peut-être pas tout tous dans tous
les cas ils ont une agilité et
particulièrement les jeunes générations
avec le numérique
d'autant qu'ils sont très sensibles non
pas seulement aux enjeux technologiques
mais alors conjugaison avec le
développement économique et la
protection de la planète
c'est une nouvelle donne avec laquelle
il va falloir composer karine de neil
votre spécialité donc c'est je le répète
la réduction des déchets la gestion des
déchets comment une tpe une pme peut
innover à travers la transition
environnementale la transformation de
ces comportements autour de la
protection de l'environnement
non donc donc ça va ça va pas forcément
passer par le numérique peut-être pas en
fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup de manières
d'aborder le sujet ça peut passer par
des changements de pratiques et des
prises de conscience que des solutions
simples et pas forcément une heureuse
peuvent être mises en place je vais
donner l'exemple par exemple de la
restauration à emporter qui a s'est
beaucoup développée ces derniers temps
peut-être que en proposant des des plats
dans des emballages consignes et ça peut
répondre à des demandes des clients
mais la solution est peut-être aussi
pour en regardant de nouveau son offre
et est ce que le client n'ait vraiment
besoin de sa serviette de ses baguettes
silva au sujet ou un certain nombre de
choses qui sont mis à côté des plats
pour pour eux emporté ça chez lui alors
qu'il a déjà touché lui donc son
approche peut très bien évoluer et
l'innovation ça d'être dans une offre où
on va afficher clairement que pourra
faire de la réduction des déchets en
venant chercher son repas dans le
restaurant par exemple
donc c'est cette nouvelle manière de
penser qui encouragés par la loi puisque
la loi et priorise c'est cette cette
manière d'agir elle dit il faut d'abord
essayer de réemployer ensuite seulement
on va vers le recyclage donc ou même
réfléchir à éviter le déchet doux
l'exemple de la restauration par exemple
donc c'est ces innovations ac ou ses
manières de faire là qu'il faut qu'on
adopte ou qu'on redécouvre peut-être
possible
finalement c'est plus de l'innovation
dans le comportement vous j'en finis
l'innovation dans l'opinion publique et
plus connus on pense directement à la
transformation technologique et c'est
votre spécialité la transformation
numérique
pourquoi elles étaient relancées plus
facilement leur activité en passant par
la transformation digitale
alors je je tiens à préciser que en tant
que spécialiste du numérique le
numérique n'est pas la seule solution
n'est pas la seule voie royale il y en a
d'autres
comme je viens de le suivre l'aig
il est important de voir tous les tout
le champ des possibles c'est vrai que le
numérique permet une palette
d'innovation qui est très importante
typiquement pour la rénover la
rénovation des habitations qui sont très
décrié en terme d'isolation en france
parce que ce qui avait été construit
dans les années passées le panier
soixante années 70 mais l'isolation
c'était pas le critère numéro un le
chantage collective était source de
dépenses énormes donc avec le numérique
et des technologies comme le bim ce
qu'on appelle le building information
modeling les entreprises du bâtiment
vont pouvoir s'approprier des techniques
qui vont leur permettre de gagner en
efficacité de pouvoir baisser les coûts
tout en protégeant la qualité des
services de façon à pouvoir développer
et réhabiliter des logements qui sont
source de création de production de co2
contre lequel on se bat tous maintenant
pour pouvoir protéger notre planète
merci à tous les deux jean philippe
dayraut ensuite en transformation
digitale et karine domaine eco experts
notamment sur la question de la gestion
et de la réduction des déchets merci
[Musique]
en collaboration avec movéo le groupe
segula technologies spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie lance un challenge open
animation intitulée segula cleantech
challenge destinés aux start-up et aux
pme pour le pôle de compétitivité movéo
qui rassemble plusieurs acteurs du
secteur de la mobilité et de
l'automobile l'objectif est
d'accompagner la relance de son côté
segula technologies veut élargir sa
dynamique en collaboration avec d'autres
entreprises regarder
[Musique]
séduit la plusieurs domaines de
prédilection est plus un secteur mais le
premier comme vous le savez c'est
l'automobile on a été impacté par le
ralentissement des activités de nos deux
gros clients français que sont psa et
renault
segula innove en permanence et j'allais
dire peut-être encore plus maintenant
en fait c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
un levier pour prendre des rester
compétitif quand le marché va repartir
[Musique]
je tiens lot d'innovations sont des
sondés excellent moyen pour les grands
comptes
de source et d'acquérir rapidement des
compétences pour pouvoir sortir
rapidement des produits compétitifs
il était question voilà de laisser aux
participants jusqu'au 10 septembre pour
déposer leur dossier de candidature
puis les dossiers seront instant examiné
du parc cellulaire d'autre part par
mauvais temps sur ce recours examinés et
les finalistes seront invités à peach et
le 8 octobre en présentiel de tous les
experts de deux cellules en
[Musique]
il se trouve qu'au niveau du département
de recherche innovation de cette villa
en travaille depuis longtemps sur des
innovations alors soit sur des énergies
des énergies propres soit sur des
projets de mobilité plus durable
on a lancé chez segula en fin d'année
dernière
un dispositif qui s'intitule explora h
le xbl au terrain qu'on présente comme
un hub de start up avec le cdu la clint
challenge moveo on est vraiment à la
recherche de jeunes entreprises que nos
compétences pourrait leur permettre
d'accélérer et de gagner en performance
et peut-être en time to market aussi la
mobilité et les transports l'énergie et
nouveaux matériaux ce sont les trois
grands domaines les champs d'exploration
de ceux de ce challenge
[Musique]
l'organisme de formation du numérique
simplon point qu aux membres du campus
du numérique de saint quentin en
yvelines organise les 21 et 23 juillet
un speed matching virtuelle des
rencontres en visioconférence entre les
entreprises et les apprenants en date
analystes et en développement web
l'objectif étant de favoriser
l'insertion sur le marché du travail de
ces personnes directement à la sortie de
leur formation
autre rendez vous qui aura lieu le
vendredi 2 octobre 2020 l'événement
horizon cyber consacrée au secteur du
numérique et de la cyber sécurité dans
la région ile de france organisée par
saint quentin en yvelines et plusieurs
partenaires cette journée par assemblée
start-up pme grandes entreprises
chercheurs et investisseurs pour des
conférences networking et rencontre avec
la possibilité de découvrir les
dernières innovations dans le secteur de
la cyber c'est la fin de ce numéro
enregistré depuis le technocentre
renault de guyancourt merci de nous
avoir suivis l'émission est à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
fou